simonas spins lost it picked up by top  and  topping it quickly quickly has it  too late mike quickly launches  and off the mark savona's the rebound  popping should have given the ball to  quickly earlier folks and then simonas  spins lost and picked up by top and  topping it quickly quickly has it  too late mike quickly launches  and off the mark savona's the rebound  popping should have given the ball to  quickly earlier folks  simonis spins lost and picked up by top  and  topping it quickly quickly has it  too late mike quickly launches  and off the mark sabonis the rebound  should have given the ball to quickly  earlier folks